では五十四番目の偈 Na
puppha gandho paṭivātameti Na
candanam tagaramallikāvā Satañca
gandho paṭivātameti Sabba
disso sappuriso bhavati
で このエピソードに次の偈もつなげてます Chandanam
tagaraṃ vāpi uppalaṃ aṭhavassikī Etesaṃ
gandhajātānaṃ sīla gandho anottaro
それから説明に入ります
まず簡単な意味 皆様もうとっくに私より百倍知っていると思いますけど Na
puppha gandho paṭivātameti
花の代わりは あの 何風？ 逆風です
逆風にはいかないんだと Na
candanam tagaramallikāvā
チャンダナっていうのはこの白檀のことで
かなり代わりのあるもので
それも代わりを作るために使いますね
で まあ煙を立てちゃうと
まあ粉にしてね 結構いい代わりはする
タガラマッリカっていうのはまた二種類だと思いますけど
それはどんな植物かと
さっぱりわからない  日本でも何か植物をお寺とか使ってるすごい代わりのものありますね
あれなんて言いますかね
かなり高価なもので 香湯かなんとかの時使いますけどね
日本のこと知ってる方はいらっしゃい
キャラとまた人工  おそらくこのタガラとかなんとかとのキャラとかそんなものかもしれません
で この代わりを立てる植物といえばね
まあ大木もありましてね
おそらくキャラも大きな木やと思います
知らない どういう木？小さな木
見たことない 輸入するんですか？あれはね
まあとにかく日本ではいくつかの種類の植物を使ってますからね
おそらく輸入でしょうね
それこそ大木でね 白檀の大木で
と言っても細い木ですけど
大きく太くはなりませんだけどね
それからこの小さな この草みたいなね
小さな植物もあります
ものすごい代わりを出してくれるもの
その中の一部なんですね
このハーブとかね まあと言って
この食料食べる 食べる時
料理に使ってるのはね
香辛料でしたっけ  そういうものは全部小さな植物なんですね
それで良かったと思います
小さな植物のは栽培しやすいし
簡単には消えてしまいませんだからね
大きな木っていうのはなかなかもう
それは料理に使う方になっちゃうとね
もう大変なことになります
そういうあの二種類は一応あります
[笑い]それから三行目でっていうのはサタンチャガンドーパティワタメティ
サタンっていうのは良い人というね
人格者ですね その人の香りは逆風にも行きますよと
それで白檀やら伽羅やら
そういうのはこの一番最高級の香りを出すものなんです
あの まあフランスでとか
なんだか作ってる香水っていうのはものすごい人工的に合成するもので
それほど体にいいものじゃないんです
で これ何も合成しなかった
この自然の香りっていうのはもう結構
あのまあ体にも心にもすごくいいもので
ですから最高級なんですね
そういう最高級の香りであろうとも
逆風にはいかないんですよ
しかし 人格者の香りが
逆風にも行きますと 次はサッバーディサー
すべての方向へ 方向 方向ですね
さっぷりそう 人格者が
まあそうやって流れていくんだということで
で 次の偈の意味はチャンダナンタガランワーピ
チャンダナ 白檀とタガラっていうのは伽羅ですね
そういうもの ウッパランアタワッシキ
ウッパランというのは花ですね
ある あの ある あの まあ水の中に
中で咲く うーんと あの微妙に青い紫色がついてる花なんですけどね
いくつかの種類がありますけど
ウッパラン かなり香りがあります
ワッシキっていうのは
あの まあ例えでしょう
あのジャスミンですね
花の中でものすごい香りがあるのはジャスミンの花なんですね
それはもう押し花にしても香りが消えません
とにかくどう頑張ってもその香りを消すことはできないんです
[笑い]まあ何年も経ってもボロボロになってこのぐらいになると香りがないかもしれませんだけど
結構ものすごいあの香りがありまして
またすごく気持ちを穏やかにする香りなんですね
ジャスミン系も花いくつかありまして
日本でもなんかジャスミンとか言ってる花がありますけど
ここら辺ちょっと歩いてみたら
どうかの家でありましたけど
もうあれもジャスミンとして使って売ってますけど
でもそんなに香りあるものじゃないんです
香りあるものは別な種類で
何種類かありますけどね
で それでお釈迦様がこの当時インドであったこの最高級の最高の香りのものを並べるんですね
白檀やら伽羅やら もう一つなんか花
水仙ですね なんとか花とか
またジャスミンの花とかね
そういうエテーサンガンダジャータナ
それらの香りあるもののよりシーラガンダウ
道徳的という香りはね
戒律がある 道徳的であるという香りがアヌッタラ
上である 無上であると
アヌッタラっていうのは無上
この上のないという意味の無上ですね
最高であるでもいいんです
はい それでまとめてみようと
まあ花の香りは逆風にはいかないが
人格者の香りが四方八方にも漂うんだよと
世の中にあるいかなる香りよりも道徳的という香りが最高なものであるということなんですね
ですから ポイントはすごく簡単でしたと思いますね
人格 道徳は一番最高で上なもの
上だということを言っているんです
で それは人格は素晴らしいんだというのは簡単ですけどね
そうすると人間というのは人格者って何？という質問になるんです
一応子供ならそう疑問は起こるんです
大人には前の業務意味わかりませんだからね
だいたいこの子供には聞かれたことはありますよ
いい人間になるって何なのかと
いい人間って何でしょうかと聞くんですよ
素晴らしいんです その質問は
なぜかというと すごい具体的で
で 大人が何か苦笑いするんですね
子供だから何も知らんからね
そういう質問するんだぞとかね
本当は逆なんです 大人は無知だから
何も知らんのだから質問しようとしないんです
ですから お釈迦様はそういうこの素直で知らないことは知らない
知るということは具体的に知ることやっていうね
まあまあ 子供もっているあの知識レベルではなくて
まあ何て言いますか 知識要求するレベル
子供にはそんなにたくさん知識があるわけじゃないんだけど
知識要求というのはできているんですね
知りたいというね この知りたいという
このレベルがすごく素晴らしくて健康的なんですね
お釈迦様の教えもそのレベルに合わせて喋ってるんです
なぜかというと その知りたいという欲求がある場合は
知ることはできるんですよ
私は知ってるんだ 私は私自分で考えて行動してるんだと思っちゃうと
もうもう鍵はもうかけてます
心に 本人にも他人にも何が入ってるかわからない
健康だけあるんですけど
中に何も まあ本当は何もないんですけどね
健康に入りきらないほど財産ある場合は鍵かけません
かけられませんからね
常にオープンなんです
心と知識の関係はそんな感じで
知識得る人は 知識ある人は常に心は開放して置いておくんですね
間違ってる知識はすぐ簡単に捨てる
新しい正しい知識が入ったらすぐ入れてあげる
で 大体子供心は道を歩む性格なんですけど
人間には知識が必要なんですよ
だから結局もう過去世でなんとか変な業をしてね
終われたんだから まあ業はまあなんとかこいつを生かしてやらなくちゃあかんと
人間として まあ適当に死なない程度ぐらい
まあ若い時 子供の時はまあ一応知識入られるようにと心はまあ開けておく
業にできるのはほんのわずかなことで
それから人間 自分の努力によって知識をどこまで増えるのかということは人間の仕事なんです
過去世で業を犯したのは本人だからね
まあ結果出る場合はそれなりの結果が出るし
その結果はすごく実るようにとするのはもうこちらの生まれてからの仕事なんです
それはあまり人間というのは
まあ一応そんなにやらないんですね
大体勉強する時でも もうとにかく早く終わりたいというね
気持ちがあるんだからね
何年かかるのかとかね
そういう気持ちが入り込んでいますからね
それがずいぶんのこれがダメなんですね
これが問題になるんですね
だから早くもドア閉めたいんです
それでこれは供養の原因に関係ないんだけど
言ったのは お釈迦様の場合はこの知識要求ある人
正しい知識要求というのは
すごい具体的に物事を知りたいということなんです
観念的に知りたいということじゃないんです
ドア閉じた人々は妄想するしかないんだから
もう観念的にすごい喜びを感じるんですよ
観念的なことに 具体的なことにはそれほど喜びは感じません
で 子供の場合はもう具体的なことにすごく喜びを感じる
それで知識が増えるんです
そういうわけで お釈迦様は具体的なレベルで答えているんです
では 人格者の代わりが四方八方に何の妨げることも障害もなく流れて漂っていくんだよと
人格者って何と と これは道徳的であること
答え出しています そうすると曖昧なく
疑いなく 疑問なく ブッダの考え方は何なのかということは理解できるんですよ
自分の主観でごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃもう解説することはできなくなるんです
もう二足す二は四であるとはっきりと決めておくんです
だから このずっとブッダの教え聞いても自分なりに考えるんだからね
仏教はどんどんもう崩れてしまうんですね
仏教は崩れるわけないんだけど
本人が理解しない状態になるんですね
それを次の世代にも教えるんだから
自分なりに考えても全くのゴミ
役に立たない機能の機能性ないものは次から次の世代に伝わ伝えていくんです
それではもう意味がないんですね
だから ブッダの根本的な元々の教えに入ってみると
その自分なりに考えるということはできないはずなんです
無知な人は何考えたって無知のからくりでしょうに
智慧の完成者がブッダが智慧の完成者だというんだから
まあ曖昧なく疑いすることなく
疑問起こることなく 真理事実を一応表現して発表しておいておくんです
自分なりに考えるんじゃなくて
それはそれなりに理解しようという努力は
人間が一人一人しなくちゃいけないんです
だから ブッダの智慧のレベルで自分が上っていくんであって
ブッダに私のレベルに降りてこいと
いうのは正しくはないんです
だからどうしても どんな教えにしたっても
実践してみるという半分はどうしても残るんです
言葉だけではまったくもうまず理解しないしね
誰でも研究したり調べたりする人々は
自分なりに考えているんだから
どうったことはないんですよ
自分なりに考えて理解しようとではなくて
ブッダの教えを理解しようということで挑戦しなくちゃいけないし
そうなってくると言葉だけではもうものすごく足らないんですよ
実践という半分もずっとあるんです
これは半分じゃないんですね
教えはもう何分かとわからないんですけど
やっぱり 真理はそんなにたくさんないんだから
もう簡単と言えるし それを実践して
おそらく九十パーセント以上は実践だと思います
でやらなくちゃいけないんです
この芸にしたっても その同じことで
さあ それまで言ったのは
この経典の解説に入る前に必要な
知識なんです どんな特色の教えでしょうかと
ブッダの教えは毎回言いますけどね
それから芸の解説なんですけど
注釈書のエピソードは読んでみましたけど
なかなか自分個人的にはこの注釈書の解説は
まあどうかなと思いますけどね
まあ何かエピソード書かなくちゃいけないんだから
注釈書ではね エピソードは見つからなかったみたいです
で 私は一回だけ大阪で学校の子供たちに一時間半ぐらい喋ったんですね
その時 ある女の子がおばあちゃんがいつでも自分にはね
いい人間になりなさいと言ってますよと
いい人間って何でしょうか
という質問をしたんです
大人は聞かない質問ですけどね
やっぱり子供は  おばあちゃん一生懸命言ってるんだからね
そう言っていることを
ちゃんと学びたいんですよ
いい人間になるのは何なのかというと
子供はわからないんです
だから 言ってる人も具体的に言っておいたならば
その疑問が出てこないでしょう
大人はわからないんですよ
いい人間って何なのかと
なのによくよく言うんです
子供に だから意味のない言葉でしつけしているんだから
子供はどんな人間に大きくなるのかということは推測できないんですよ
なんで自分の子供はこうなったんですか？こんな大人になったんでしょうか？誰もわからないでしょう
そんなはずがないでしょう
育てるのは自分だから
このような大人にしてやるぞと計画立ててちゃんとやれば
そういうふうになりますよ
どんな人間にもなります
でも どんな親でも 自分の子供はどんな大人になるのかということはわからないんです
しつけは一生懸命はする
しかし あれはしつけじゃなくて
意味のない空の言葉をずっと流しているだけ
それで子供たちにもやがて嫌になるのです
意味のない言葉ずっと言いっぱなしだったらね
なんか外国語でずっと喋っているような感じなんです
苦労はしますよ なんとか理解してやるぞと
で 顔の形やら手ぶり身振り見ながら
でもやがてそれでも疲れますからね
それでうるさいと 反抗的になるんです
この反抗時期っていうのは
そういうしつけが悪い家庭でだけ起こることで
全ての人間にある生物学的なものやってことじゃないんです
それは私は一応試してみたことが
ものすごいたくさん もうこの反抗する時の子供たちにはね
いろいろ関係 付き合いやりましたからね
意味のあるように言うと
反抗の時期ってなくなる
全く反抗しないことになるんです
単なるもう子供は まあそういう子供は突然大人になるだけ
突然と言ったっても まあまあまあ
いきなりもう何でもかんでも自分でやりたくなるし
大事な責任持ちたくなる
今まで親がやってきたものは
まあ私がやりますと ただそれだけ
それを親が厳然嫌がるものじゃないんですよ
父親が運転した子供は
もうやがて息子が自分で運転する
もう私がやりますと あんなこともなく
自分が運転席に座ってもう待っているんです
で 家族が乗っちゃえばいいんです
それはもう反抗時期がなく
単なる大人になったということなんです
母親が買い物をしようと色々リストを書くと
もうこれはダメ あれは要りませんとかね
こうこうすればどうですか？そちらにも口を挟んで何とか言う
母親から見れば まあやっぱりその通りだとわかる
逆に大人がまあどうすればいいでしょうかね
この場合はとかね まあ聞いたりもする
すごい立派な大人になるんですよ
まだまだ子供は子供なんですけど
その場合は反抗っていうことはないんです
性格は変わって大人になることは確かにありますけど
反抗して独立するっていうことはね
しつけが正しくなかったら反抗する
ただうるさいということしか出てこないんです
もう嫌だと 私のことは放っておきなさいということになるんです
だから 残念なことに この大人はまあ物事を理解しないんだから
ただ言っただけでいいわけじゃない
それで私はあの女の子がね
いい人間って何？と聞いたとたん
私はまあそこら辺ずっともう頭の中で遮っちゃったんですけど
そんなのは子供に言っても意味がないんだから
ちょっとどう答えればいいかな
私も結構引っかかっちゃったんですけどね
で こちら言ってるのはその同じことなんです
この二つ 二つの偈で言っているその質問に答えなんです
すっぱりと これです もし子供がいい人間に成りなさいと言ったとしても
何よ？と聞いたら もしこの二つの偈を知っているならばね
こういうことだよ と言えば
すごく具体的に私はこういう
こういうことをすればいいんだとわかるんです
それで 1番目の偈でいうのは
この人格者の変わりが四方八方に何の障害もなく漂うものであると
いわゆる世の中で どこででも
だからいい変わりが来たということは
ものすごく喜んで認めた
受け入れたということでしょう
だから世界に受け入れる人間というのは人格者ですと
人格者でなかったならば
もう社会では受け入れない
その人 ですから社会人として成功できません
受け入れないんだから
社会の中できてなくちゃいけないんだから
だから社会から追い出そう
追い出そうと あっち行けあっち行けと言うと
行くとこないでしょうに
どこへ行ったっても 人間が社会にいなくちゃいけないんでしょうに
あっち行けと言ったら
あっち行ったらそちらも社会でしょうに
そちらからあんたあっち行きなさいと言っちゃうと
そちらもまた社会でしょうに
そうすると人格がない人はもう追い出されて追い出されて
同じ人格がない もう負け組のところに
あるいは犯罪者のところで
やがて転がって転がって
そちらに落ちてしまうんですよ
そこで腐っちゃうんです
我々もいらないいらないと捨てているものは
やがてゴミになるでしょうに
どんな家で大事にしているものでも
使わないものだったら
引っ越しする時でもゴミになるんです
時々まあもう高いお金を払って買ったものだからとなんとか言って
あの置いては置こうとするんですけど
まあやがてそれがまあ要らなくなる
電気製品の場合 一番わかりやすい
いい品物 すっごく高いんだけど
二 三年経つとあれよりも機能の良い大きさの小さいものが出てくるんですよ
まだ値段も安いし 前のものより
だから かなり高いお金で買ったものはまるっきりゴミになってしまうんです
まあ人間作るもので あんまり簡単にゴミにならないものといえば
まあ車ぐらいですね 車はもう最初からもう基本的な機能は揃っていたんです
人を騙さなかったんです
まあそれからまあまあ少々少々まあさらにレベルアップするだけのことで
新しい車が出たんだから言って古い車は使えなくなったわけじゃないんです
まあ一応ボロボロになるんだから
自然の流れでその時処分すればいいんです
今もありますからね あの初期時代の車
あのすごい丁寧に手入れして
あのクラシック車とかね
で まあ手入れすれば かなりあのまあ真鍮とかね
例えばヘッドライトの枠は真鍮なんですね
それはもう磨いておけばピカピカで
あのクラクションはないんで
操縦そんな電気 あれはあのゴムで
大概これをそれを押すともう音は出ている
まあギアというか あれ
かなりの大きな棒で でもあの動きますよ
当時作った時のスピードで動くんです
まあそれ まあそんなもんでね
だからこのまあ車とかだったらそんなにね
まあ一応基本的なもの
他の品物っていうのは
結構簡単に古くなっちゃうんですね
古くなったんですけど
買った時はもうすごいお金いってしまったんだから
どこかで捨てられなくなっちゃって
まあ置いておく で その時点であっち行けという気分になってますよ
もう しかし やがてそれがゴミ
なるんですよ まあ人間の場合はいきなり１日にして犯罪者になることはないんだけど
人格できてない人はやっぱりその世界からちょこっとまあ無視されたりして
あまり受け入れられなくなると
なんか自分もちょこっと居心地が悪くて
もう我慢できる時間いて
また別なところに転がらなくちゃいけないんです
そちらにも合わないと
また別なところに転がらなくちゃいけない
人格ない人はそうやってもう転げて転げて
もう社会の一番この まあ英語ではスカムというんですけどね
何て言いますかね 垢 悪ですね
あの料理作る時出るものはね
まあアクが出ますね あれ要りませんね
同じものから出るんですけどね
食べるものからね で そういうところに行ってしまうんです
だから 人間は人格者にならなくてはいけないということ
特に若い年代の人々はまだ一人前になってないんだから
どんなに大人になるのかというと
人格者になることなんですね
それはもう決まっていて
もう他は何もないんです
答えは これが唯一な答えなんですよ
人格者になりなさい そうすると自分のことはどこででも代わりのごとく受け入れられる
受け入れてくれる だからこれが人間に対してはもう会社で問題あるならば
家庭で問題あるならば
もうどこでも社会で人間関係で問題あるっていうことは
人格ができてないっていうことなんです
強情で高慢でわがままで
自分の考え方で相手を何とかして押し付けて押し付けて抑えて生きてみるぞという
まあ恐ろしいところなんですけどね
自分が生きていなくちゃいけない社会が環境でしょうね
環境を抑えてどうなるんですかね
よくやるでしょ それが
自分立ってる土台に対して攻撃して
だからわがまま 高慢とか
それは自分が立ってる土台がもう崩れかかってくだけなんです
だから言うんですね やっぱり会社でもうちょっと人間関係うまくいかないとかね
家庭でいろいろトラブルばっかりだとかね
これ人格ができてないっていうことなんです
でも答えがみんな聞きたくないんだから
私もいろいろごまかしで
まあいい人間関係築く方法とか
なんとかくだらんことばっかり言っても
そんなもう本何冊も書く必要でも何でもないんですよ
書いたっても書いたっても
もうもうもう答えと 一行で言えますからね
それだけは聞きたくないでしょ
正解だけは言うなよと
言うと怒るんですね だいたい人間関係悪い人もうまくいかないと言った時はみんな喜ぶ答えがあるんですよ
会社でも上司が悪い やっぱりもうその連中はけしからんやと
あんた言ってることは正しいんだと
そんなもう出来の悪い人間の中であんた大変でしょうねと言ったらすごく喜ぶんです
信者さんならいくらでも獲得できます
あなたの人格の問題ではありませんかと聞いちゃうと一回きりです
こちらの瞑想に来る人はそうでしょう
結構初めの方々来るでしょう
一回きりでしょ それ言いますからね
たまたまこちらも疲れて
もうなんとか適当に 瞑想教えたり
もうもうほとんど説明もしてないし
まあなんとかなんとかもう
その場合はもう何回何回も繰り返してくる
答えはこれですと やるべきことはこれですと言っちゃうと
もう終わり もう二度と口を利けなくなるんです
まあ大体大人の世界っていうのはそんなもんで
大体子供っていうのはそういうことはあんまりしませんですけどね
まあそれ知識要求がある子供はね
もう 10歳の時でもね
もう人生は終わってる連中もいますけどね
ゲームやって遊んで もう食って寝ることだけ人生だと思っている
早く大人になっちゃって
まあそういう子供以外は
やっぱりまあ一応またまた聞きたくなる
攻撃してみたくなるんですね
まあそういうことだから
それ私は言ってるのは事実であって
この正解だけは人間聞きたくないんですよ
だからそれはもう私は知ったもんじゃないし
まあだからいくらブッダの教えを教えても
なかなか人間っていうのはもう変わらないんですね
変わらないのは人間は永遠というわけじゃなくて
もう無常の塊なんですけど
この鍵かけてもう新しい進化しないようにしているんですね
進化しないようにしたっても腐るだけでしょうに
だって無常だからね 無常だから変化するのは止まりませんよ
それで無常だからもういろいろもう腐らないような方向へ持っていこうか
持っていこうかと こちら頑張ってます
仏教の方は 進化しましょうと
進化は無常だからできるもんでしょうに
進化したくないというと
それで退化して消えてしまうんです
だから心に鍵かけてね
まあ知識入れないっていうことにしたら
まあそれでその人はそれでしっかり人格ができたわけじゃなくて
もうどんどんどんどん腐れて腐れて
壊れて壊れて壊れていくんです
腐って腐っていくんです
いくら凶暴でいても生活しても
やがて社会からゴミ扱いされる
年取ったらどこかの老人ホームに放り込む
あれ 壮大ゴム処分のやり方だからね
それからお見舞いに来ない
それって成功した人生かと
成功した人生だったら捨てられません
社会を受け入れる 成功した人なら
子供たちの間で孫たちに見守って
みんなと仲良く喋って死ぬことはできるんですよ
だから社会に受け入れられる人間にならなくちゃ
社会は人間生きてる土台なんです
社会に受け入れられる人間っていうのは人格者になること
人格者はどんな国でも問題なく生きていられます
次の問題は人格者になろうと言ったっても
何をすればいいかという子供が聞く質問なんです
大人も人格と言ったらよく知ったかぶりしますけど
私も人格者と思ったりしがちですけど
あれって本当は反対なんです
見栄張ることやら 傲慢で生きることやら
自分で人を抑えて 人の考え方も何でもかんでも抑えて
自分のやり方でやって生きていて
それで成功しているんだと
そういう人格者と勘違いするんで
あれ人格者じゃないんです
逆なんです 人格は全くもないという
で あの 知ってる人は知ってるかもしれませんだけど
この世間でよく立派な人だと褒められて認められて
知名度はすごくある人々と仲良くしてみればがっかりするんです
親しくしてみればもうがっかりするんです
あれって何ですか？と
あれは人格者ではなくて
ただ強引に強情で もう社会を抑えただけ
自分の名前を売り込んだだけ
その人には生きることは楽じゃないんです
隠すものはいっぱいあるんです
だから行ってみればがっかりするということになるんです
[咳]